la gare de sainte geneviève des bois
fait partie des cinq pôles gares situées
sur le territoire de coeur d'essonne
agglomération qui porte le projet
avec sept mille deux cents voyageurs par
jour un train la ligne c du rer et cette
ligne de bus la gare souffre aujourd'hui
de dysfonctionnements l'offre de
stationnement pour les usagers est
insuffisante et impactent l'accès aux
commerces ainsi que la quiétude des
riverains
les dénivelés des cheminements piétons
sont trop importants
la gare routière n'est pas accessible
aux personnes à mobilité réduite
les cheminements pour les vélos ne sont
pas lisibles pour améliorer l'expérience
voyageurs et répondre aux besoins des
usagers et habitants card et son
agglomération
la sncf ile de france mobilité et la
ville de sainte geneviève des bois ont
engagé un plan de réaménagement de
grande ampleur une véritable gare
routière accessible sera créé une
passerelle permettant l'accessibilité de
la gare une liaison urbaine entre les
deux quartiers de la ville et assureront
la continuité des déplacements doux sera
construite des zones de dépose minute
seront aménagés et l'offre de
stationnement sera améliorée les travaux
au niveau de la gare débuteront dès
l'année prochaine
le projet de réaménagement s'intègre
dans un dynamisme de projets
structurants pour la commune et vise à
mieux articuler des espaces publics
améliorer les flux des voyageurs et
créer un environnement à la hauteur du
développement du territoire
[Musique]